From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, we're going.
This is Saturday 4 June 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill,
with the the cameraman John Bishop and we are in Albany, Georgia at the Southwest Georgia Civil Rights Movement 53rd Reunion,
here on the campus of Albany, Georgia.
And we're very grateful for the opportunity to sit down with Rev. Charles Sherrod.
Thank you very much for making time.
This is an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Reverend Shrod, we mentioned before we started today that we focused right in on the work you did when you arrived here to build the the Albany Movement.
Yes, I came in about October 1961 when just the experience behind me were the Gillian and Rockill South Carolina.
I was in South West Georgia after coming from Rockill and it's been a month or so and jailed there on the chain game,
which brought together a lot of my feelings about the movement, the the eighth chapter of Romans that carried me the rest of the way until now in the movement.
It had very important meaning to me while in the Rockill, jail, chain game.
And I brought that with me to Albany.
I persuaded that nothing can separate me from the love of God and Christ Jesus, our Lord, a simple verse, but very meaningful to me.
What it meant was that nothing but death could stop me from the mission that I had of developing our people.
And I brought that with me to Albany.
But it took me time to understand how to get the old fellow who said, y'all know us, while looking down straight at the ground, he's talking to a white man, a woman in front of him.
I never understood, or it took me a long time to understand how to touch a man like that.
And the indignity that women had when they went into stores to buy a hat, for example, to try on a hat.
You could look at all the white women trying on hats, but knowing that when they tried on a hat, they had to put a stocking cap over their head, and then try on the hat.
And they would then pay their money and say, yes, ma'am, no, ma'am, paying their money.
How to break them away from fearing the giant in the county, the sheriff?
And to go down to the courthouse was to go down to the courthouse and face the sheriff.
It took us all of a month, because after getting permission from the elders, you know, it wasn't as if the movement had wasn't doing anything, the people weren't doing anything.
They had voter registration drives, trying to get people registered to vote.
The Criterion Club in Albany, Georgia went to the City Commission and asked for paved streets and better lighting in their neighborhoods.
They didn't get anything, but there was activity there, I'm saying. So there were leaders, there was some leadership in Albany before I even came.
But when Charles A. Jones and Cordell Reagon and myself got the permission from the adults and the community to bring the movement into Albany, Georgia, we felt good.
First, we talked to people who were just natural for us to talk to. At 19 and 20 and 21 years old, we had to be talking to young people.
So we talked to the young people first. And we got small numbers of young people, 10, 20, 30, 40.
Young people who come to meetings in the small churches where we were allowed to come. The first church was the Presbyterian church in the city.
The other churches took a little time to think about it, because the word was that wherever the meetings were going to be held, the churches were going to be burned down to the ground.
There were spread all over the area. And some churches were burned down to the ground, so they made good their promise.
But how do you get the fear that all people had out of them to stand up to the sheriff and stand up to the police, stand up to the chief, the prison.
And the answer was our children, but our children had not been persecuted. They had not known in a Pharaoh. They were afraid of that moment and that.
So after talking with them and week after week and talking about nonviolence, because we were going up against a group of people who could deal with violence. They were looking for violence.
If they could promote violence among us, then they could break us. But these young people, they could not break. If we confronted them with love, we were talking about confronted them with love and confunding and expecting peace from it.
And so, although I can't remember a time that we lined up in the church before marching, that we didn't find at least one switchblade knife.
We had gangs that we recruited to march with us nonviolent. We were successful at that. We had four gangs, east side gang, west side gang, north side gang.
All of us had four gangs. And we had representation from all four of those gangs among the young people. We had high school kids and we had all of them in the state college kids.
And when the time came, they were ready to march. They were ready to, I think our first project was the integration of the bus station, the local bus station.
And Charles A. Jones and I in Cordell tried it out first to see if we really were going to arrest. And we found that they were going to arrest.
But one of the first things that came out of this was the feeling of strength that the people felt. And the showing of strength that the people showed after they arrested their children.
Because after that, our first march we had, when about 255 people marched with us, we came and we filled two churches. Two churches were right in front of each other.
And we had a lot of people in the church, Shiloh Baptist Church and Mount Zion Baptist church. They were filled. And there were large numbers of people milling around in the streets outside of both churches as well.
And I said there weren't two to three thousand people at that particular meeting that we had. And so the strength that we showed made us all feel good.
And so hundreds of more people went to demonstrate after we had taken the first groups in. And that was the plan to keep on until we filled the whole jail system.
And they had to take us, until we filled the Albany jail? And then they took us to the Jails and the Americus, Georgia and some some to county, Terrell County, Georgia, Baker County, Georgia, Mitchell County, Georgia are the same kind of that we would eventually go back to and organize.
And it was just a great joy to find the same old people, bent over, talking with the head down, we're now talking with the heads up. And speaking to white people without fear and demonstrating, you know, going in the store and taking, trying on that hat.
And picket and stores who would not change in their morals. It was a great day for Albany and the strength that we showed by marching together, but still loving.
In face of the hostility and in face of the relative savvy of Laurie Pritchett and managing the distribute all the prisoners across these many county jails.
This is a very fluid time you're pioneering new techniques, finding a way forward. You're the first field secretary really trying to find out how to make this work.
What was your mechanism for continuing to make your choices about how to move ahead?
What was my...
How did you, how did you charge a course? What were your best ways to make your decisions about how to progress ahead?
Okay, first of all, I didn't make all the decisions and the SNCC guys didn't make all the decisions. We made decisions together. We had a steering committee, the Albany Movement steering committee.
And most of our strategy came out of the steering committee. But we did...
Our first effort was to desegregate all public accommodations. And we did that by picking in...
First of all, when we were talking to people on their business, asking them, would they please change their policies? Then when they would not change their policies, then we would picket them.
So if something happened at a particular store, somebody got hurt or somebody was smacked or changed thrown on the ground or something like that, then they allowed us to pay more attention to them.
Especially people who had 90% black business and didn't have anybody on the cash register, they also attracted our attention.
And so we went to them and talked to them, look, we know that we got... we do more business here than anybody, any group. And by right you should reciprocate and allow us to make some money while you make money.
And if they... one store was... was... Smith Grocery, I believe it was. We picketed it for two days and it closed.
And I guess other stores seeing them closed, open their doors and start hiring. But they did it against the wishes of the City Commission.
So the Commission really wanted to continue the segregation policies and the business people feeling the hurt wanted to change because ultimately they really didn't care about what that policy was.
It wasn't anything to put money in that pocket. Well, it was taking money out of that pocket. So they wanted to stop segregating their customers. But it was a city policy to do so.
Same thing with the bus company. We went and talked to the bus company. Bus company wanted to integrate it right away. They were willing to hire some black people and put on those buses. But the city was against it.
So they weren't... they weren't eager to continue driving empty buses around town. And that's the kind of effectiveness that we had.
When that girl was thrown off the bus, zoomed. Nobody rode the buses. We started our own system of transportation. We did what we had to do.
And soon the city began the transportation system on the operated by the city.
Let me ask you one key event where maybe the fear was felt as closely as ever. And there were so many times when the fear was so close and so extreme. But the night of the night of the church bombings, Saturday.
Can you describe that? What you want me to tell you? I'm on the oven and I'm talking about Baker County, Georgia. We had many mass meetings in Baker County, Georgia. And our strategy was in Baker County, Georgia came from the Baker County, Georgia Movement.
We had a leadership all of us together deciding to make a demonstration of learning news people from around the country that we're going to integrate the voting process.
And so this day was a very pleasant day beginning. And we had about 150 people in line and a long line from the church there to the courthouse.
And as we walked toward the courthouse, I could see without looking my peripheral vision could see a number of white young men with ax handles coming toward our group.
There were at some point behind my vision, but I didn't hear them hitting them about it back and then hear them about the screaming back. So I know they were coming out possibly coming out to me.
And so I didn't I didn't do anything but continue my walk until I start feeling blows on my head. Knocked me down into the street.
And I was bleeding profusely from all over my body on my head for a reason. And they beat me down into the ground. And then the only saving grace that I had was an old lady who had been in our nonviolent direct-action workshops.
And where I taught them to throw their bodies across one another to shield the blows of one person was being attacked and share the blows with him. And so that saved my life. They stopped. She screamed out stop you're going to kill him. You're going to kill him.
And that's what all I remember when they took me to hospital and all been it.
Last question because I know we're just up against our time here. This has been quite a weekend of celebration and memory.
Do you have any just observation about how the weekend has felt for you?
Well, it's just been great number one to see people who I haven't seen in 50 years. Some I haven't seen in 10 years, 15 years, so for two years.
Those are one great thing. The other thing is that two good things happen during this one week we sign contracts.
And we had an announcement that we are radio station. We got a license for radio station. And we had we signed a contract for New Communities Inc. land of land.
For those two projects and the celebration is just too much goodness and happiness and blessings to bear. But we thank the law for them.
Thank you very much for sitting down. That's Reverend Sherrod. It's been a real privilege and honor. Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.